what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today okay I am
going to be red pilling women
so I bring I bring girls on my show
which is three times a week every
Wednesday Thursday Saturday 9 p.m
subscribe and on the show I tell people
red pill topics
and
today I'm gonna be showing you Jordan
Peterson before before I start though
guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell that
way you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos and why don't you introduce
yourself to the people
um my name is Yasmine
um I'm 22 I'm from London
um
have you ever heard of Jordan Peterson
well
don't know much about him but I hear his
name going around okay yeah okay so just
a little context okay
Jordan Peterson is a psychologist okay
and
um he
um got in trouble because he didn't want
to use
um trans pronouns
right so there was a law in Canada that
was passed okay and in Canada
um basically they said you have to use
people's trans pronouns right sounds
good on paper but the problem is he he
doesn't believe in compelled speech
do you know what that means so he
doesn't believe that the government can
force you to say something right so it
wasn't about like the trans movement it
was about the the speech he felt like
that law was unlawful okay like he felt
like that shouldn't be a thing because
it's controlling yes yeah yes like he
thinks he should be able to say what you
want yeah so he said he came out and
said I'm not gonna do this okay and
obviously it has backlash yes because
people were thinking the trans Community
right but it also yes and it put him on
the map though that's what people know
him for and then he also did like a
self-help book so he he's a psychologist
so he helps people like
I don't know improve and you know get
better mentally so
so so this is um an interview he did
that was supposed to be about his book
okay okay
that men need to quote grow the hell up
tell me why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it it people
who don't grow up don't find this sort
of meaning in their life that sustains
them through difficult times and they
are certain to encounter difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so you
say I mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying it's the crisis of masculinity I
mean what do you do about it
you tell you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't uh shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like why it's more like a
delineation of the kind of destiny that
makes life worth living I've been
telling young men and but it's not I
wasn't specifically aiming this message
that young men to begin with it just
kind of turned out that way and it's
mostly you admit it's mostly men
listening I mean it is then your
audience is amazing well it's about 80
on on YouTube which is a YouTube is a
male domain primarily so it's hard to
tell how much of it is because YouTube
is male and how how much of it is
because of what I'm saying but um
the
you you what I've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's going wrong then
oh God all sorts of things have gone
wrong I I think that
I don't think that young men are hear
words of encouragement some some of them
never in their entire lives as far as I
can tell that's what they tell me and
the fact that the words that I've been
that I've been speaking the YouTube
lectures that I've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that young men
are starving for this sort of message
because like why in the world would they
have to derive it from a lecture on
YouTube now they're not being taught
that they that it's important to develop
yourself does it does it bother you that
your audience is predominantly male does
that isn't isn't that a bit divisive no
I don't think so I mean it's no more
divisive than the fact that YouTube is
primarily male and tumblers female isn't
it tumblr is primarily female right
you're just saying That's the Way It Is
Well it's I'm not saying anything it's
just an observation that that's the way
it is um there's plenty of women that
are watching my lectures and coming to
my talks and buying my books it's just
that the majority of them happen to be
men uh it's what do you think so far
I don't disagree okay with anything that
he's saying I do think a lot of
males do need words of encouragement
because I do feel like females get more
of that than males ever would just
because
females are
notably
um
the less agenda yeah agenda so why would
people would be give it in words of
encouragement
empowerment phrases all that kind of
stuff to the less agenda than expecting
it from the men and some people just
don't when some males just don't have
that and do fiend for it do you I don't
think of women as the lost or gender
in regards to now what's happening now
though you don't think no no because I
just think like women in general were
like we're catered to more than men
there's a lot of men that are like
really really lonely yeah like I've had
guys DM me where they're like I've never
had a girl be interested in me ever no
yet no but that's because you do say
that majority of the girls are in that
20 looking for the men that 20 bracket I
totally hate you in that but I feel like
women have a lot of influence
on specific
elements whereas men also have influence
on other elements and I feel like the
elements that they do have influence on
are more powerful okay than what women
have influence on no I think there's a
small percentage of men that have a lot
of power but I think like men as a whole
like the bottom like 50 of men they're
like we don't see them yeah we don't no
we don't see them we don't see them at
all I just feel like they're so deemed
to do well in life that actually has the
reverse effect on some some other men or
the majority mm-hmm
we're gonna it's gonna get good you wait
you wait what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you rely on women
have some sort of Duty to sort of help
fix the crisis masculinity it depends on
what they want
no I mean it's it's exactly exactly how
I laid it out like women want deeply
want men who are competent and Powerful
and and I don't mean power in in the in
the in the in that they can exert
tyrannical control over others that's
not power that's just corruption power
is competence
and why in the world would you not want
a competent partner well I I know why
actually you can't dominate a confident
partner so if you want domination you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no I'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution
I think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and I think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their Partners
although their Partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that I mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women I mean you're making these vast
generalizations
I'm a clinical psychologist right so
you're saying you've done your research
and women are unhappy dominating men
I didn't say they were unhappy
dominating men I said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame I mean there
can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time but it's no formula
for a long-term successful long-term
relationship that's reciprocal right any
long-term relationship is reciprocal
what do you think about what he's saying
I like semi
agree
I certainly agree just because I've had
seen women who do dominate their partner
the male partner and is miserable yeah
and it but I I don't know what it is I
do feel like women do want a sense of
protection when it comes down to having
a male partner just because of how they
are perceived as and just I guess it's
just also biology as well to the point
where you just want to feel protected so
I
I have seen some women I have seen
someone who dominate their milk and
they're they're miserable they're both
miserable they are they are very
miserable and it's I don't see in the
younger generation I see in the older
Generations yeah
don't see it in the younger generation
no well I think the younger generation
of women would rather be by themselves
than with those guys yeah and that's
like why we have so many guys that are
like lonely yeah but the older
generation they're like well I don't
even know what I don't even know what
the reason is if you really think about
it because
I feel like maybe because nowadays a lot
of women are encouraging women
empowerment be by yourself yeah don't be
with someone that you don't match as
your own values and morals like if
either if he doesn't see who who you are
or who you want them to be don't be with
them you know what I mean there's no
but back in the day I don't think they
had that so then they if they can
dominate
they will well I think it's also because
the guys they want don't want them no
guy wants a girl that's like dominated
no no they don't like they don't they
don't they don't they're like wow if we
get a boss a boss check that's what
everyone knows some there are some males
that actually like it isn't it it's
because you don't want like it's the
yeah they really they call them betas in
the manosphere yeah
beta
I always say keep your beta ass husband
like I have no some women I know at
least what three to four women who
dominate their relationship their male
partner and they're not happy name them
[Laughter]
Adam what the name of Shame no but it's
true
um and like that's what I think he's
kind of trying to push is like men being
more masculine and like stepping more
into their roles of like leaders but I
don't think they I don't think men have
to be masculine I just feel like
I just I just agree with his point where
he says women who do dominate their
relationships
um well Partners do end up unhappy not
saying that you can't dominate sometimes
yeah the majority of the time I agree
with that but that's that's like a
that's a masculine trait it's leadership
yeah I know it is yeah but I feel like
do you not feel that it's pushed onto
them a lot to be that way no I think
society says you don't have to be that
way and I think it makes them unhappy
like I think I think Society lies to men
and says we want men that are
emotionally unavailable and like equal
partnership all this stuff we don't
actually want that and so then the men
try to do it and they're like why can't
why can't I get these hoes because
technically we don't we still want yeah
elements yeah so let me put a quote to
you from the book well you see there are
whole disciplines in universities
forthrightly hostile towards men these
are the areas of study dominated by the
post-modern stroke neo-marx's claim that
Western culture in particular is an
oppressive structure created by white
men to dominate and exclude women
but I want to put to you that here in
the UK for example let's take that as an
example the gender pay Gap stands at
just over nine percent
you've got women at the BBC recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies yeah so it
seems to a lot of women that they're
still being dominated and excluded to
quote your words back to you it does
seem that way but multivariate analysis
of the pay Gap indicate that it doesn't
exist
that's a gap between median hourly
earnings between men and women yeah but
there's multiple reasons for that one of
them is gender but it's not the only
reason like if you're a social scientist
worth worth your salt you never do a
univariate analysis
you say well women in aggregate are paid
less than men okay well then we break it
down by age we break it down by
occupation we break it down by interest
we break it down by personality but
you're saying basically it doesn't
matter if women aren't getting to the
top because that's what's skewing that
gender pay Gap isn't it you're saying
well that's just a fact
you're going to get to the top no I'm
not saying it doesn't matter either
you're saying there are multiple reasons
for it yeah but there's reasons why why
should women put up with those reasons
I'm saying that the claim that the wage
gap between men and women is only due to
sex is wrong and it is wrong there's no
doubt about that the multivariate
analysis have been done
multi-berry
I'm saying that nine percent pay Gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women I'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid nine percent less than a
man that's not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening I can
give you an example
okay there's a personality trait known
as agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite and agreeable people get paid
less than just less agreeable people for
the same job women are more agreeable
than men
again a vast generalizations
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men so you were
saying that by and large women are too
agreeable to get the pay Rises I'm
saying that that's one component of a
multivariate equation that predicts
um salary
I was watching I remember watching
something and it was it was about gender
pay Gap and it was about the country
Rwanda and another
um I think it was kind of I'm not sure
about how they've decreased the gender
Pain by
a ridiculous amount I think it was
something like I don't know two percent
Gap and it was because they um
implemented some sort of I even know I
can't even speak wholeheartedly on it
because they've implemented some sort of
social structure to help women actually
achieve those goals
so when he comes down and says that it's
not specifically down to gender I do
agree but I feel like the main reason is
because of gender
how just because if you think about it
if there's a man and a woman
the woman gets pregnant
the man still has the opportunity to
continue to work right so he continues
to work he probably has more of a chance
to get a promotion building the the
going up there where the woman actually
statistically stays the same if not goes
down just because she's working this out
because she's pregnant so then
if she wasn't pregnant she still
wouldn't have been able to get to that
same level as the man so in my personal
belief I do feel that gender is the main
factor to one
do women out of the choice to not have
children of course yeah they don't they
have the choice to work as much as men
no they do yeah so how is it isn't it by
personal choices rather than gender
because at the same time because a guy
could choose to stay home with the kids
if you want yeah but they don't well
majority of them end up not taking the
maternity or paternity yeah which is but
like that's choices yeah and I think
when you give people more choices
there's going to be more disparities you
know certain groups have like things
that are alike yeah so like for example
I'm German and Germans like like they
always have a really hard work ethic
like they work a lot of hours everyone
in my family Works long hours it's just
that's just my family yeah and like but
that's that's a group preference so if
you take Germans versus
another group like there might be a pay
disparity but you like and if you look
at it at the surface they might say oh
it's like that's because of you know
race or because of something else but
it's really because of the culture yeah
but you could you could say that the
culture has implemented them to who to
be who they are so for example
um women have been brought up in society
to be at home with the child right
consistently over many years so then
when it comes down to your choice it's
like okay maybe I do resolve to this
because this is what we've been taught
to do from a very young age for a very
long time well do you do you think that
society when Society like I've been told
from a young age you can do whatever you
want like I I've heard the feminism
narrative since I was young which is go
to work you could put your career like
you don't need a man you don't like you
don't have to depend on anybody so I
don't like like in my experience I don't
think Society really pushed families to
be honest and you're seeing it because
half of women like 50 percent of women
over 30 are single and childless they're
saying like our generation is going to
be less married less like and less
children than any other generation yeah
I can believe that so if but if Society
is pushing it like why where are the
results because even though
you're saying over 30 50 of women don't
have and by 30 90 of your eggs are gone
no yeah I know yeah when is the average
hit menopause do you know
um I would guess like 50 is no 45 maybe
45 I was gonna say 45. you know but
yeah so like if it was Society like I I
don't see Housewives being pushed in
society ever I've never been pushed to
be a household yeah but I think that's
Choice isn't it yeah if you become a
housewife that's because you want to be
a housewife I mean I feel like you can
if you wanted to if you didn't if you
were a housewife you didn't want to be a
housewife you would have done anything
in your power to not be a housewife do
you know for me yeah yeah but like what
I'm saying is like I don't think Society
pushes
being like like staying at home because
if they did then you would see
Housewives like being revered everywhere
yeah like that would that would be what
everyone's being pushed to do and I I
just don't see that I feel like it was
like that and now it's coming to a point
where it's not as much but I still think
the
um
the reasoning is still the same in
regards to a lot of women do tend to
stay at home because we haven't got to a
part where our generation is the last
generation you know I mean we still have
Generations previous to us who have been
at home with their kids for years so you
have the influence of your family
members being like okay but you need to
stay home for your kid like the mother
needs to stay home for the kid this than
the other so
it's a hard one because until like
unfortunately those Generations die off
maybe we'll see change in regards to I
think the um gender pay Gap has
decreased over the years but it's not
going to be anything major until
this generation does because like you
said it's going to be the generation
that has less kids and you know what I
mean but like why do you like why do you
want to see change if that's what people
want to do what do you mean like like to
me I I think change is only good if
people want to do it so if women are
wanting to stay home and that's what
they want to do like why would we want
to see change
I think if that's if that's what they
want to do yeah they want to do it if
they want to do that and they want to do
it but I feel like the majority of
people my Joker women don't want to do
that anymore well and they're not yeah
so so you're kind of seeing it but like
women also they're going to go more into
this video but like like like I think
equality just for equality's sake is is
pointless no there's no there's not
gonna be yeah yeah so if there's no laws
in the way stopping women and society's
not pushing them like it seems like it's
what they want to do is stay home
I see what you're saying I just feel
like there's still
an element of
it being pushed onto women to stay at
home it might not be as much it was it
was what it was but I still feel like
there is that requirement almost that
a female should be with her kid rather
than a male being with a kid yeah he's
gonna go more into it he's he's this is
the guy he knows like no like honestly
I'm open
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely you need about another 20 you
need about another 18 factors one of
which is gender and there is Prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay Gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay Gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay rise make yourself disagreeable with
your boss oh definitely there's that but
I also didn't deny it existed I denied
it it existed because of gender okay
because I'm very very very careful with
my words so the pay Gap exists you
accept that but you're saying
I mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to us for pay Rises one of
the reasons okay one of the reasons so
why not get them to ask for a pay rate
many many times in my career and they
just don't oh they do it all the time
you can it's so one of the things that
you do as a clinical psychologist is
um assertiveness training so you might
say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
um and you and and maybe the next most
common category after that would be
assertiveness training and so I've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical and
Consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period did you
celebrate of course so do you actually
do you agree that you would be happy
if that pay Gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how The Disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying the cost of
men that's a problem Oh there's all
sorts of things that it could be at the
cost of it could even be at the cost of
women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay no because it might
interfere with other things that are
causing the pay Gap that women are
choosing to do like having children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demanding they
do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large I'm
saying that that no I'm not saying that
I'm I and I actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no I said that what was making
them miserable was having art was having
weak partners
that makes them miserable right um I
would say that many women around the age
of I would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and I think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to get the major pieces of
their life put together faster than men
which is also partly why men aren't
under so much pressure to grow up so
because for the typical woman
um she has to have her career and family
in order
pretty much by the time she's 35 because
otherwise the options start to run out
and so that puts a tremendous amount of
stress on women especially at the end of
their 20s I think I take issue with the
idea of the typical woman because you
know all women are different and that's
why I want to just put another quote to
you from the book that's different in
some ways and the same in others okay
you say women become more vulnerable
when they have children and you talk to
one of your YouTube interviews about
crazy Harpy sisters so before they go
into that what did you think of that you
know what I agree because I feel the
pressure and I'm only 22. you know what
I mean yeah yeah I like I feel I'm sorry
I feel the pressure of like growing up
needing to get your and everyone's like
to me calm down like you're still young
I'm like yeah but I feel the pressure
yeah grow up get a career do what I have
to do and then have a family like
sometimes when I see like girls having
babies at 18 19 nothing's wrong with it
but I'm like
it would scare me do you know what I
mean it scares me because I'm like damn
like so
I feel like having a kid does like put
some of those does limit you to certain
aspects so if you don't have that
already
in motion I feel like it's gonna be hard
for you to do it after I mean I haven't
experienced it obviously because I'm not
pregnant or had a kid but that's how I
feel well yeah because when you have a
kid it's not about you anymore yeah like
it's it's about that yeah so they come
first yeah exactly so no I I feel that
pressure too because I'm 25 and I'm like
oh my God I'm freaking oh my God
I'd be lonely
I'm lonely
no but like it's bad like but it's it's
just kind of like biology though do you
think that's what it is yeah like I
think why because
I just think like we live in a society
that tries to get rid of our gender
differences
so even when you're talking like I think
more women want to stay home because
biologically I think like we're more of
nurturers than men and I think like
women naturally we want to have kids
like because you know you might some
girls say oh maybe not now but I think
if they were Barren tomorrow they'd be
devastated you know it's one it's one
thing when you can choose to not for now
it's another thing when the clock's
running out so when you're 27 28 and
you're not married and in two years 90
of your eggs are gone and then in five
years you've got geriatric pregnancy
you're trying to find a man quick I
think that's and then you say after the
career because the second half of your
life like a career's not gonna fulfill
you when you're 70 60. I feel like the
only reason why people try so hard to
get a career between their 20s to 30s is
to feel satisfaction and say okay cool
I've got that done now yeah let's move
on to the next which is having a
childhood family but but to build like
that that extreme income you you have to
put in more than 10 like and I know
that's 100 I watched my dad do it yeah
he worked 80 hours a week
20 30 years I don't want to do that have
the same dad because my dad would spend
God knows how many hours and he's like
he's got his own business own man like
he's very very very successful and I'm
like to him I can't imagine how much
stress and how much
it would be to put in those hours trust
me like as an athlete you do get to feel
that as well but it's different well
it's different when you do it for 20 or
30 like exactly life whole life and I
think women like we don't we don't want
to do I don't want to do that yeah like
I'd rather have like you know a balance
but I think women like we just naturally
like want that and I don't think it's
Society I think it's just like innate
what to want a balance more like I think
between the genders well I just I think
men naturally protect and provide more
and I think women are naturally more
nurturers there's exceptions but when
you look at in general so you literally
just think it's just down to biology
that's the reason why
fair enough the yeah we're gonna he'll
he'll go into it a lot of a lot of these
ideas come from him so I give credit
where credit's due guys I give credit
where credit's due so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never gonna happen
depends on what you mean by equality
men and women getting the same
opportunities
fairly people we could get to a point
where people were treated fairly or more
fairly I mean people are treated pretty
fairly in Western culture already but we
can but they're really not though are
they I mean otherwise why would there
only be seven women running ftse 100
companies in the UK why why would there
still be a pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the BBC saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
that's sort of the first question
they're both complicated questions seven
seven women repeat that one there's
seven women running the top ftse 100
companies in the UK that question might
be
um why would you want to do that
why would a man want to do it
I know there's a lot of money there's a
certain number of of men although not
that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life to the
pursuit of a high-end career so they'll
work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the talk so you
say women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not a nice
life I'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so I work so you you
don't think there are barriers in their
way that prevent them getting to the top
there are some barriers yeah like other
like men for example I mean to get to
the top of any organization is
incredibly competitive Enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position so let me come
back absolutely all-out Warfare is
gender equality a myth
I don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable if it means
equality of outcome then almost
certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in Scandinavia
because in Scandinavia what do you mean
by the equality of outcome is
undesirable well men and women won't
sort themselves into the same categories
if you leave them alone to do it off
their own accord I've already seen that
in Scandinavia it's twenty to one female
nurses to male something like that it
might not be quite that extreme and
approximately the same male Engineers to
female engineers and that's a
consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inerradicable differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're saying that anyone who
believes inequality whether you call
them feminist cooling whatever you want
to call them should basically give up
because it ain't going to happen only if
they're aiming at equality of outcome
see why does she I hate this hate this
it's like she she kind of twists out she
he says something like without
tremendous societal pressure that men
and women would not be equal I agree
with that yeah like because like
engineering do you know girls that are
dying to be Engineers no I haven't I
don't know one girl died to be an
engineer so the only way it would happen
is if Society was like making us do it
yeah no I agree
no it is a bit like I feel like women
dominate in some sectors and Men
dominating the other I don't see a lot
wrong with it if it's like almost equal
playing for them regards to what dumb
who dominates work but it is hard for
women to get to the top I mean at the
same time
like men are like women still are scared
for their own health and safety when it
comes down to like and all that kind of
stuff like women still come down women
still are
I feel like those are the barriers that
do stop them from going further up
because there are people who are just
willingly malicious to bash you back
down do you know what I mean no you
don't get what I'm saying no no like so
if I if I want to get to the top of an
organization I'm worried about saying no
it's not even great for you too great
like so I'm worried about getting graped
no not great but like oh we can't see it
no it's okay just just for the algorithm
um
it's just the fact that
it just I just feel like
women are scared honestly to go to move
upwards just because of the
repercussions that may happen so maybe
they stay in their safety bubbles
so that's what prevents them from moving
forward do you not matter more likely to
be victims of a violent crime than women
I mean I don't believe that they are you
know you're gonna have to show me some
statistics I will yeah well from women
no from oh no that's understandable yeah
men killed men um all the time but
men from women and women from men like
it's different oh oh for sure no because
matter it goes back to the personality
differences like men are more
disagreeable if you're highly
disagreeable you're more likely to
commit a crime yeah but like so so if
you're the average like a normal guy
like who who's not committing crimes
like why why is he like what what
difference is it if he's an average guy
he wouldn't be at the top though would
he well no no I'm saying that as in like
like not crazy like just a normal guy
who wants to get to the top of an
organization he also is he's more likely
to be a victim of a violent crime so he
also could be afraid of
being assaulted or whatever yeah but so
how is that a woman's issue it just
seems like that that can be either way
yeah just I just feel like for women
that would be more prominent than it
would be from a man to receive that
balance from a man you know what I mean
no so like if there's a woman and a man
or yeah the same position right
and we're talking about the violence
that they would receive I feel that the
woman will be more susceptible to that
violence than the man would I just I
don't think that's like because I worked
in Corporate America right so I worked
for a billion dollar big big company
right and
I wasn't if I got a promotion I wasn't
afraid I was gonna be assaulted
like that just doesn't make sense
like because I feel like because you're
saying like to get to the top of an
organization women are afraid of like
getting great no I said that's another
boundary that's another boundary right
but I'm saying I don't think it is
because if I'm getting it like I worked
in sales so if I wanted to be the VP of
sales like that's that's the top of that
organization at a billion dollar company
that's one percent I'm not afraid that
if I get promoted they're gonna grape me
like or my co-workers are gonna grate me
like that's that's crazy but it happens
not often not often but it does but it
doesn't happen often because not a lot
of women go to the spot well I'm saying
it also like if a man goes to the top he
could be assaulted too but it doesn't
happen as much as women they're more
likely to be victims of a violent crime
than women
but from
from a man they're not who cares who's
like if I'm getting assaulted I don't
care who's assaulting me no you're
pissed either way yeah so if you're a
guide you're getting assaulted like I
don't who cares who does it I just I
just I just feel like women I don't know
what the fact is but I I feel like women
are more susceptible to getting that
repercussion just because they are a
female and that are trying to move up in
either corporate business or whatever to
get to the top there is going to be more
of that repercussion onto them than it
would be on to men but but if men are
more likely to be victims of a violent
crime like then how how would they be
more likely to have that Reaper but that
violent crime I would just assume that's
a lot of a lot from I don't know
criminal Gang Related type of crime you
know I mean not more in the corporate
business sector so so you're talking
about like Harvey Weinstein type stuff
you don't know who Einstein is
why you don't have a Weinstein
Weinstein's like the the I think that
happens in Hollywood a decent amount
where like um you sleep with someone to
get the role yeah but I also like I
don't like because there there was a
series where like like this guy was
basically saying it in order to get big
Parts in movies you had to sleep with
him but do you see how that's just like
yeah it's not a it's not a it's not
violent but it's still like well but
it's also women using their looks to get
to the top I think girls like choose to
do that too yeah like there's girls that
try to sleep their way yeah maybe
because they're not educated in the way
of how to get to talk about doing that
or because they don't know because they
want a shortcut it's the same reason
girls go on only fans because they want
quick money they want it to be easier
yeah you know what I mean like you would
never do that you would never sleep with
someone to get to the top just I would
never do that because I just feel like
right what because you get yeah no I can
tell we played again like I can tell you
work hard you'd never do that I would
never do that but some girls they just
they just want an easy yeah
and then after they'll like cry about it
but you weren't crying when you got the
role died like like
you were crying when you were it's
I know they're regretting it in the
moment it's just it's just I can't
fathom people actually doing that so it
is a bit we're 50 of the population some
of these hoes be trifling like
like it's it's a big group I just
yeah
all right let's go let's go you'll think
give people equality of opportunity
that's fine not only fine it's eminently
desirable for everyone for individuals
and for society but still women aren't
going to make it that's what you're
really it depends on your measurement
techniques they're doing just fine in
medicine in fact they're far more female
Physicians than there are male
Physicians there are lots of lots of
disciplines that are absolutely
dominated by women many many disciplines
and they're doing great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison Beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well I made the argument there it's like
it depends
no I'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
so I mean are we going back to the
doctor we're actually not listening
and I'm hearing you basically saying
women need to just accept they're never
going to make it on equal terms equal
outcomes is what how you defined it no
idea
I would go well I might as well just go
and play with my Cindy dolls and give up
trying at school because I'm not going
to get the top job I want because
there's someone's sitting there saying
it's not possible
desirable that's what they said it's a
it's a bad social law I didn't say that
women shouldn't be striving for the top
or anything like that because I don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no I
think I really the patriarchal system is
just silly I do I think that's silly I
really do I mean look look at your
situation you're hardly unsuccessful
exactly good battling is good this is
all about inevitable but you talk about
men fighting let me just put another
thing to you from the Bible you're
saying you have to paddle for a high
quality position
what
she's such a I don't get it she's like
so what battling is fine I mean you have
to you have to battle to get to the top
yeah
like you like I get it I get it I can
just hand you money like when he went to
like no making money is hard send
donations please
help us sister
it is like what she would say was
absolutely ridiculous I think she was
just in the moment of panic I had to say
something honestly like well I heard
that after this interview she thought
she won
I haven't heard the whole interview so I
can't even tell you but right now from
what she just said there no like you
have to battle to get you have to work
you don't annoys me he's actually doing
something to help women he actually
helps women negotiate salary he's making
us or women more aware of what is
actually happening and and what are you
Kathy what are you doing Kathy like what
are you what are you doing Kathy you're
just sitting on a talk show
I'm sure but I'm saying like how are you
directly helping women he is like so
it's like you're hitting the hand that
feeds on me yeah like oh my gosh this
lady's so annoying I do not like her
Kathy but if you actually I should react
to a video with Kathy Newman what video
would you do this one I'd be like Kathy
let's talk about this
you probably haven't won there real
quick
well I noticed in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote an underlying threat of
physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversation
between women is that something or are
we sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that the domain of physical
conflict is sort of off limits for you
to get where I've got yeah but what does
that make me well I don't know I don't
imagine that you've yeah to some degree
I suspect you're not very agreeable so
that's the thing successful women I'm
not very agreeable right I don't have
that actually in this conversation at
least and I'm sure it served your career
well successful women though basically
have to wear the trousers in your view
they have to sort of become men to
succeed is what you're saying well I've
had to fight
succeedings man certainly masculine
traits are going to be helpful I mean
one of the things I do in in my
counseling practice for example when I'm
Consulting with women who are trying to
advance their careers is to teach them
how to negotiate and to and to be able
to say no and to not be easily pushed
around and to be formidable and you need
to if you're going to be successful you
need to be smart conscientious and tough
well here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some male bosses shall we
say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay Rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay well I would
say partly because it's not so easy to
determine what constitutes the same job
because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our Industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the terms
for so long that women have to battle to
not like them it's not true it's not
true so for example well I can give you
an example very quickly so I worked with
women who worked in high-powered law
firms in Canada for about 15 years and
they were as competent and put together
as anybody you would ever meet and we
were trying to figure out how to further
their careers
and there was a huge debate in Canadian
Society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by men it's not
the market is dominated by women they
make 80 percent of the consumer
decisions that's not the case at all
people who stay at home looking after
children by and large they are still
women so they're going out doing the
shopping but that has changed
okay so what a market is driven by women
not men right okay and if you're a
lawyer they still pay more for the same
sort of goods that's been proven that
men for the you buy a blue bicycle
helmet is going to cost less than a pink
one anyway we'll come on to that partly
because men are less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it I
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
I'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business I mean maybe they
wouldn't they don't predicting the
banking crisis they don't predict
success in the workplace the things that
predict success in the workplace or
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
companies no I didn't say that at all he
said that female traits don't predict
success but I didn't say that
intelligence wasn't I didn't say that
intelligence and conscientious
oh no I mean that's certainly not saying
that at all are women less intelligent
than men no a lot no they're not no the
the data on that's pretty clear the
average IQ for a woman in the average IQ
for a man is identical there is some
debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
James damore pointed out for example in
his memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men and men are a little
bit more industrious than women but the
difference isn't big but that averages
into quantity can you imagine you aren't
necessarily well of course
so why are they not feminine traits why
are they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable at the topic it's hard to say
I'm just laying out the empirical
evidence like what'd you think I'm like
chewing and throwing like he'll say
something I'll be like okay I could see
him she would say something I'm like
okay I see it I'm like in the middle
okay yeah it's interesting though isn't
it yeah it is like I you don't think
about this stuff
yeah like you don't sit there and be
like it's hard to find points unbiasedly
and argue yourself in your head yeah do
you know what I mean yeah but um
she says something he says something
that you have to present masculine
traits to get to the top because those
are what deem to be successful whereas
feminine traits
are not deemed to be successful so as a
female you would have to gain some of
those masculine traits to be deemed as
successful so does that make
female traits weaker or yeah
I mean so it's like when she's saying
that
why I would why wouldn't the top people
or the males reduce or Implement some of
the female traits they wouldn't do that
because it's not deemed successful why
would they do that or does it make them
money right but yeah no exactly but I'm
thinking what made it that way well okay
I'll give you an example okay so um on
I I run a business right and I have a
really hard time firing people like I
it's so hard for me someone disagreeable
it's not hard yeah it's like it's quick
you're doing a bad job get out yeah like
that because that makes you more money
you don't waste money don't waste money
same thing with negotiating right so
like if someone asks me for this salary
I would make the most money if I gave
them the lowest but I give them like
like someone asked for this isn't that
big of a difference so someone asked for
like between 10 and 12 pounds per hour
dollars per hour whatever it was and I
gave them 12 even though I could have
probably given them nine if they're
asking for 10 to 12. that then if they
get paid less I make more money if I
make more money then I can invest it
into equipment and therefore the
business makes more money but if you're
disagreeable you say no take nine right
but also yeah right and that makes you
more money but on the other side you
could say that the reason that you're
giving this guy a promotion is because
he's earning your company more money so
you would give him a promotion because
you're in turn earning money right no
for sure but the thing is like as an
employer you're the way you compete is
by making the most money possible so
it's getting them to do the most work
for the least amount of money and this
isn't like a fun but that's why you you
need to negotiate every salary as as the
employee but sixty percent of women have
never
negotiated a salary so it's not it's not
saying these traits are bad
they're good for different reasons I
just I just feel like the majority of
the female traits that
are presented on strong enough
to get to where these melt but what I'm
trying to think is why is it that that
is the case like
is it because of the how how do you
think it's because how men have created
the society to benefit them in a way
or do you get what I'm not even I'm not
even know if I'm wearing it properly but
it's it's the trait disagreeableness
right do you think that's what it simply
that boils down to yeah like okay I'll
give you an example so on teams I I'm
the type I've been passed over for
Captain positions a lot in my life what
don't say of course
you show it you know what I mean so why
would you why would you not be but no
passed over like I didn't get them oh
you said pass like on two no no no no no
I was like audacity that's okay it's
okay it's true though it's true but it's
because I I'm not the type to take
charge of a room right I'm I'm the type
to like talk to you one-on-one and maybe
like say oh come on my show whatever but
I'm not the type that's gonna be yelling
at you about the drills I'm not the type
that's gonna do that you don't have to
be yelling to be no but but the girls
that do that tend to be captains more
right because it's a leadership quality
I'm not I'm not knocking it I think you
need you need girls to do that like
that's that's fine okay no I'm yelling
as hell no
and I can tell you probably Captain
alone right yeah but that's
that's a bad thing it'll probably make
you money right but but in business like
like that's that's who you want the
leaders the people because when you're
the boss you you can't be friends all
the time you have to be able to like
lead and direct people and that's that's
the trait disagreeableness it's not it's
not a bad thing for me but like in even
though we don't make money in sports but
say we say we say we dead okay like the
captains would probably make the most
money and I would make less money
because I'm more agreeable it's that
trait it's like taking charge being able
to tell someone no that does better in
business it's not a bad trade it
probably will make me a really good mom
someday but because it's more nurturing
and loving but it's like you can't have
everything yeah no no I agree no that I
agree if it did make me think like it
didn't alter a little bit it was to
because I always had an issue saying
like Okay why aren't women climb into
the top like what is it and I remember
when we were sitting down over there and
use like a personality difference yeah I
was like I said it we're also my way of
thinking because it actually
can be personality different that leads
on to other stuff yeah I mean so if you
actually break it down maybe it's just
personality difference yeah you know
what I mean yeah and it's not it's all
like I don't enjoy this
I'm not I'm not gonna I want to copier
sales for two years I didn't die bruh
but but a disagreeable person would say
I'm not going to put up with that either
pay me more or give me a new job yeah
and like the agreeable person is like oh
no it's fine that doesn't do well it
doesn't make people money
why do you think we're like that
um I think historically like we had to
get along with a man to survive so you
think
if that wasn't the case we wouldn't be
the way we are now
I think we like we would have been I
just got this yeah I think it's our
biology like we're meant to like take
care of the the kids but that's why in a
lot of fields where women Excel it's
with people
because we can okay you know what a girl
gives you a dirty look at a bar yeah no
and the guys are like and the guys are
like what are you talking about yes it's
because women can pick up on more social
cues than men so we do better in fields
with people but they don't pay as much
like plumber why don't they pay as much
because it's supply and demand right so
like like there's less people willing to
do the jobs with things like engineering
and and competent enough to do it so
like plumbers Engineers so you think
it's just because there's more labor in
it that's the reason why it's probably
because my my stepdad he's
um a structural Industrial Engineer so
he just builds like a Scaffolding in
there if a big corporate companies and
I'm like
I see the drawings and the scales it's
like a lot of work right so I'm thinking
Okay cool so
is that the reason why
engineering and Scaffolding all that
kind of stuff has so much like people
paying so much money coming in and out
of it because it's such a I don't want
to say tedious but a lot of Labor yeah
like it's it's it's dictated on like two
two maybe three things like one is how
how competent you have to be to do it
right so if it's super difficult not a
lot of people can do it so so then you
have to pay those people more right
because not a lot of people can do it
right and then on top of that like how
many people are willing to do it so if I
if I post a job right and I have a
hundred people that apply I can pay the
person I pick less because if you're not
going to do it I have a hundred people
but if you post a job and five people
apply and only two of those are
competent enough to do it you have to
pay them a lot because if if like if I'm
posting that job that means someone
else's too like you have to compete for
the work of course and if there's more
workers like you don't have to compete
from as much so why is like the industry
such as like for example
private healthcare when you have nurses
the majority of nurses that come in why
are they paid
less
because it's you're looking off the
human beings you're looking after life
the life has life that doesn't have a
value to it does it so it's like well I
don't I don't I don't know enough about
like the UK Healthcare System but I'd
imagine it's because there's a lot of
nurses so if you're not gonna do it I'll
pay some it's like it's what are the
workers willing to accept right so if I
offer you let's say 30 000 right and you
say no I'm not doing that okay well if
if there's five more nurses equally
qualified I'll just ask the next one
until someone says yes right if everyone
says no Then I then you raise the pay
but as a business you're trying to make
it the most money possible like
yeah because then like because then what
do you do with that money you can pay
certain people more or you can invest in
new equipment or you can invest in new
you know Technologies for the people at
the facilities yeah so it's it's all
it's it's not you know fun but
everyone's just trying to make a dollar
send money
[Laughter]
Super Chat
in the in the premiere right now you
know who you are if you've watched two
or more of these and you haven't set a
Super Chat help a girl out help a girl
or at least like the video
we know that we know the traits that
predict success but we also know of
course companies by and large have not
been dominated by women over the
centuries we have nothing to compare it
to it's an experiment true and it could
be the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it I'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical because
the evidence suggests well it's fine if
like if someone wants to start a company
and make it more feminine and
compassionate let's say and caring in
its overall orientation towards its
workers and towards the marketplace and
that's a perfectly reasonable experiment
to write my point is that there is no
evidence that those traits predict
success in the workplace and there's
evidence being tried well that's not
that's not really the case women have
been in the workplace for what at least
ever since I've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you um and this is you
got in trouble for refusing to call
Trans men and women by their preferred
personal pronouns
it's not actually true I got in trouble
because I said I would not follow the
compelled speech dictates of the federal
and provincial government I actually
never got in trouble for not calling
anyone anything right that didn't happen
wouldn't follow the change of law which
was designed not once it was lost no no
they said it was designed to do okay you
cited freedom of speech in that why
should your right to freedom of speech
Trump a trans persons right not to be
offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive I mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
Truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well I'm I'm very glad I put you on the
spot well I'm great
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine I think more power to
you as far as I'm concerned so you
haven't sat there and
I'm just trying I've just tried to work
that out I mean
bro she's having like an aneurysm screen
she's like uh she's like she's like she
knew kind of what he his point was valid
didn't kind of know where to go from
that
um
I just I just think
yeah he's exercising his freedom of
speech doesn't mean that he's being
sensitive towards therapy he's being
quite insensitive to the fact that trans
people do pick their own pronouns
whatever the hell whatever they want to
pick and
him choosing not to say is that what
he's doing
is quite insensitive but yet again he is
exercising his freedom of speech if
that's but I don't know why would he not
want to if the government says this is
what you have to do why is it such a bad
thing for him for him to not do that if
it respects someone else's morals and
values why is it bad for him to why does
he see it as a negative thing why does
he see it yeah so he doesn't he's sad in
a personal like if I had a student and
they asked me to call them that yeah I
would do it of course but what I'm not
gonna do the government can't tell me
what to say and he was protesting that
law what was what was the law the law
was saying that the basically that
people had to use people's preferred
prone so if you were trans okay the law
says you have to call like call you a
guy so I would have to say he or Zer
whatever pronoun you want to be illegal
yes otherwise it would be illegal and he
said you can't do that you can't tell me
what to say
because because you have to risk being
offended
to like live you can't like because the
when you start telling people what to
say that's government overreach and so
if you if you start saying okay you
can't you can't say that to offend you
can't sorry I'm like butchering this you
can't use the like you have to use their
pronouns if the government says that
what's stopping them from saying okay
you can't say anything bad about the
president
you can't say this you can't say that
like like it's a slippery slope to what
they can do and that's if you look at
any tyrannical Society like like North
Korea
how many things are they not allowed to
say there yeah I don't even have like
social media
yeah
and so that's what he was saying he was
saying in a personal setting I probably
would use their pronouns but I will not
be told what I can and cannot say okay
fair enough so he's not arguing the
point that he wouldn't call a trans
person by their pronouns he's arguing
the point that yes he wouldn't
what's the word he's not going to be
forced source to say something which I
understand technically I don't know why
they would make that a law yeah in the
first place and me out of respect you
would do it anyway yeah do you know what
I mean like and if you're not going to
do it anyway then you're just not
respectful person that's something that
you have to do with yourself you know
what I mean but trans people I think
that they're delusional yeah and I don't
agree but but I don't understand like if
I wanted to pretend to be black you
wouldn't think I was delusional I mean I
don't know I can't like I know there's a
point to argue it I just can't
it's like you think it's different
I do think it's different I just
it's hard it is hard I'm not gonna lie
to you it's like
I don't know I just
sometimes people are just born
with for example man sometimes a man is
just born with less
um masculine traits or more female
traits and then that ends up turning
into more of a feminine than he's like
he admires the way women are and wants
to be more like that no one's saying
that he's biologically a woman but I
guess that's because
he transitioned from having male
attributes to female attributes so I
really want to have 17 year old
attributes that tend to be more in
between
there like like I know your fuel it's
like delusion like that you'll never be
a woman you'll never have a period
you'll never be able to go through for
anything like that yeah and like you'll
never like be an actual woman so like
why are we fueling this delusion now
like girls have to pay for it we're
losing we're losing [ __ ]
like
um the the swimmer
that that could that took the that
competed in the ncaas oh yeah I know I
heard about it because we're fueling
this delusion you're saying you're a
real woman are you nuts you are not a
real woman like that looks like a dude
with long hair just killing these These
Hoes and we play basketball right yeah
we like you know damn well that like the
boys team at our school would not
annihilate us even if we were really
we're not that great like even if we
were you know like like the London Lions
the boys would kill the girls even
though the girls are way like they're
phenomenal best basketball players I've
ever seen in my life that are girls
it's it is it is a very I don't know I
even know how to argue the point I just
I just feel like if you feel a type of
regardless of you being black or
whatever because oh that was under 17.
yeah I'm 17 and black oh just I
identified
thank you no no but I I feel like I can
get the I can get why people think like
that because sometimes I catch myself
and like okay but you can't really
compete in a women's sport no like you
technically can't compete in a woman's
sport but then what happens then what's
the solution kick them out no because
then you're denying their chance of
actually competing what if they want to
compete
just like I don't
I don't join like that'd be like be safe
let me be president of the black student
union I identify yeah we would kick you
out so fast yeah
that's fine
we should do that too like like I just
think sometimes people are meant to be
excluded you can be included in
everything yeah like I know it's hot
it's a hard one there are tournaments
that are for people that are 5 10 and
Below or five eight and Below like for
short people
so would you make like
there's not enough trans people to make
a trans I'd be they can do with me go
make your own division stop get out of
them that's not enough women's rights
tell women's rights to our own division
yeah so I don't know just by
okay come out kick him out well it's not
starting
hit [ __ ] too no and kick them out of
our bathrooms I'm just saying I'm not
trying to I'm not sure I think I think
the whole bathroom thing
the only negative side I see from it is
just danger to the women but I feel like
if we have we've got a p you've got a p
i don't know if you're trying to have a
man or a woman you're trying to go and
do a locker room yeah
okay yeah no not a changing room which
is a bit different but then it's like if
you let them in the bathrooms that
they'll come in the changing rooms
there has to be a line you know that
they have to draw the line somewhere I I
think before bathrooms that's my line
get out yeah
philosophy is in any way comparable
sure that's no problem the first thing
is is that the philosophy presumes that
group identity is Paramount
that's the fundamental philosophy that
drove the Soviet Union and maoist China
and it's the fundamental philosophy of
the left-wing activists its identity
politics doesn't matter who you are as
an individual it matters who you are in
terms of your group identity you're just
saying murder is so to provoke aren't
you I mean you are a provocative right
that you hate to be compared to you want
to stir things up I'm only a provocateur
insofar as when I say what I believe to
be true it's provocative I don't provoke
maybe
I thought he's arguing oh like he hasn't
even raised his voice
ma'am ma'am set out now and then I'm not
interested in provoking but what about
the thing about you know fighting and
the lobster tell us about the lobster
um I gotta explain this that he Compares
people to lobsters in his book because
we have the same like nervous system or
something okay it's some smart person
thing I didn't really get it okay but
basically like he Compares people to
lobsters and in terms of like
hierarchies and the way humans set up
it's like very similar to lobsters oh is
it something don't don't quote me on
this I'm butchering the lobster part I
read this book a while ago well that's
quite a segue well the first chapter I
have in my book is called stand up
straight with your shoulders back and
it's an injunction to be combative
um not least to further your career
let's say but also to adopt
a stance of ready engagement with the
world and to reflect that in your
posture and the reason that I write
about lobsters is because there's this
idea that hierarchical structures are a
sociological construct of the western
patriarchy and that is so untrue that
it's almost unbelievable and I use the
lobster as an example because the
lobster we we divulge from lobsters in
evolutionary history about 350 million
years ago common ancestor and lobsters
exist in hierarchies and they have a
nervous system attuned to the hierarchy
and that nervous system runs on
serotonin just like our nervous systems
do and the nervous system of the lobster
and of the human being is so similar
that antidepressants work on lobsters
and it's part of my attempt to
demonstrate that the idea of hierarchy
has absolutely nothing to do with
socio-cultural construction which it
doesn't let me just get this straight
you're saying that we should organize
our societies along the lines of the
lobsters
I'm saying that it's inevitable that
there will be continuity in the way that
animals and human beings organize
organize their structures it's it's
absolutely inevitable and there is one
third of a billion years of evolutionary
history behind that right that's that's
so long that a third of a billion years
ago there weren't even trees
it's a long time you have a mechanism in
your brain that runs on serotonin that's
similar to The Lobster mechanism that
tracks your status and the higher your
status the better your emotions are
regulated so as your serotonin levels
increase you feel more positive emotion
and less negative emotion so you're
saying like the lobsters we're hardwired
as men and women to do certain things to
sort of run along tram lines and there's
nothing we can do about it no I'm not
saying there's nothing we can do about
it because it's like a in a chess game
right there's lots of things that you
can do although you can't break the
rules of the chess game and continue to
play chess biological your biological
nature is somewhat like that is it sets
the rules of the game but within those
rules you have a lot of leeway but the
idea that but
one thing we can't do is say that
hierarchical organization is a
consequence of the capitalist patriarchy
it's like that's patently absurd it's
wrong it's not a matter of opinion it's
seriously wrong
aren't you just whipping people up into
a state of anger and not at all
divisions between men and women you'd
stirring people up you know you have
people any critics of you online get
absolutely lambasted by your followers
generally
sorry your critics get lambasted by you
I mean if they're actually responsible
not at all if an academic is going to
come after me and tell me that I'm not
qualified and that I'm not I don't know
what I'm talking about
now quit the abuse quit the anger Well
we'd need some substantial examples of
the abuse and the anger before I could
detail that question there's a lot of it
out there for well let's take a more
General perspective on that so I have
had 25
000 letters since June something like
that from people who told me that I've
brought them back from the brink of
Destruction and so I'm perfectly willing
to put that up against the rather vague
accusations that my followers are making
the lives of people that I've targeted
miserable Jordan Peterson thank you
Professor nice talking was it Jordan was
it nice what was it being polite
would you so what did you think of
Jordan Peterson
decent guy yeah yeah I think he's a
decent guy
um
you change your mind at all
um he made me or make you think a little
different yeah he he did give me more
points to think on
and like like I said like I'm so open to
having my like the way I think yeah once
you see it you cannot see it yeah no 100
so
I do I actually do enjoy I did enjoy
listening to him yeah yeah because some
of the frankly scene is like okay yeah I
can I can see that and it made
um what's her name
yeah
looks like a bird okay what are you
talking about yeah I was just like what
are you talking about how cool would it
be if I got around the here though and
reacting to it with it hilarious you
need to do that send the email
Kathy Kathy come on come on
um no I think it's like I really
appreciate you coming on though because
I think these conversations happen off
camera so I just try to like bring It
Forward yeah because I feel like girls
like talk about this [ __ ] just like
behind the scenes it doesn't like I
don't think they even think about
putting it out that you know what I mean
but I need to know how lobsters get
depressed
because he said even antidepressants in
the works and losses I need to know how
they get depressed well I think he's
talking about like hierarchies so I I
assume it's like them at the bottom
nobody likes being at the bottom no one
does but okay guys
um I swear to God if this didn't save
I'm gonna be so sad I think it did
though I I think it's just you need to
know how to open that fire yeah I don't
know what the hell I don't even know
what you did it's I know what I do it is
okay
um guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell tell
them where they can find you
um you can find me on Instagram at I am
yassi.x
um
okay they don't have YouTube
Oh I thought you had one no I mean I do
but okay okay guys don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time